hola hola cómo están bien bien quemados
qué pasó aquí yo estaba acá atrás
guardadito bueno yo soy jose luis reyes
soy empresario también soy como un tipo
estudiante de tiempo completo de la vida
y de las emociones entonces el día de
hoy quiero empezar con esta fotografía
que pueden ver por aquí soy yo brincando
de emoción de alegría de adrenalina
ganando la competencia internacional de
emprendedores más grande del mundo y
como pueden ver en esa imagen no sé si
alcanzan a ver un detallito pequeñito
les puse ahí como una imagen armar
rayitas para que vean el brinco tan
grande que di que yo creo que fue como
por aquí más o menos y como estoy
chaparrito el brinco yorke cuenta por
dos no entonces a ver es que si dio un
brinco muy muy muy muy grande fue
muchísima emoción mucha adrenalina mucha
energía la brown y acá una experiencia
inexplicable en esta competencia
estuvimos participando 2.250 proyectos
de 67 países del mundo y el día de mi
cumpleaños me convertí en el primer y en
el único latinoamericano en ganar la
competencia a nivel internacional y como
éste tengo además bueno me dieron un
premio de 100 mil dólares nada
100 mil dólares padrísimo la verdad por
eso brinque no crean que nada más así
porque entonces como este reconocimiento
tengo otros siete reconocimientos que
quiero destacar uno muy importante para
mí que ha marcado mucho mi vida en el
año 2016 me convertí también en el
primer lugar de la competencia de
jóvenes líderes de barack obama una
iniciativa de la casa blanca en el cual
participamos 4500 proyectos de 36 países
del mundo y nuevamente como ya se los
dije gane el primer lugar entonces
empiezo con esta imagen y empiezo con
esta historia porque generalmente cuando
me invitan a hablar a foros y a eventos
oa lugares como éste casi siempre
hablamos como de emprendimiento hablamos
de innovación
hablamos de felicidad hablamos de cosas
súper positivas y la verdad es que el
día de hoy le quiero dar la vuelta a la
plática y lo que quiero platicarles a
ustedes es acerca de lo que hay detrás
de esta imagen y detrás de esta foto
detrás de esta emoción detrás de esta
adrenalina la realidad es que hay
muchísimo miedo entonces yo hoy quiero
hablar de un tema que nunca he hablado
de mi vida literalmente que es el miedo
para las personas que me conocen un poco
más saben que yo soy súper intenso
un lector adictivo realmente me gusta
mucho estudiar y entonces empecé a
entender que el miedo era un tema que
quería estudiar y que quería profundizar
entonces no nada más fue un tema como de
investigación en gabinete que significa
como en computadora o en libros o en lo
que ya existen muchísimos investigadores
sino que además hicimos una
investigación con 272 personas en la
calle y les preguntamos el impacto
directo que tiene el miedo en su vida
entonces lo primero que tendríamos que
hacer es entender y fue un primer como
la premisa del estudio entender que
nosotros todo el tiempo vivimos con
miedo todo el tiempo vivimos en un mundo
de miedos porque porque desde chiquito
nuestros papás nos enseñaron que pues
teníamos que cuidarnos que tenían que
teníamos que nos con precaución todo lo
que vemos en la novela lo que vemos en
las películas lo que nos dicen nuestros
amigos siempre nos están codificando
acerca del miedo entonces existen dos
tipos de miedo uno son los miedos
naturales que imaginemos que se empieza
a incendiar el escenario y agarro mis
cosas y me salgo bueno ni agarro mis
cosas porque no trago nada más me salgo
corriendo o imaginemos que de repente
entra una pantera por aquella puerta
todos salimos corriendo o entre un león
todos
corriendo por más que nos digan no corre
no grita una empujó todos corremos
gritamos empujamos porque viene una
pantalla corriendo detrás de nosotros
entonces esos son los míos naturales
pero la verdad es que es muy poco
probable que entre una pantera que se
incendia el escenario el otro tipo de
miedo que es en el que estudiamos en el
que profundizamos en el que yo he vivido
constantemente son los miedos mentales
son aquellos miedos inventados
construidos creados por nuestra mente
completamente como podríamos decir como
adaptados por nuestra vida entonces
estos miedos mentales son los que fuimos
a estudiar y entonces fuimos con estas
personas y les preguntamos oiga señora o
señor o joven jovencita usted vive con
algún tipo de miedo y nos dimos cuenta
que el 73 por ciento de las personas que
encuestamos si viven con algún tipo de
miedo y el 27 por ciento dijo que no
vivía con ningún tipo de miedo entonces
como el tema de esta plática es acerca
de la felicidad de las emociones de
vivir mejor les preguntamos juega señor
señora usted cree que se puede vivir
feliz con miedo y el 60% de las personas
nos dijo que no que no se puede ser
feliz con miedo
y el 40 dijo que sí entonces si
indagamos un poco más y preguntamos por
qué no se puede ser feliz conmigo y nos
dimos cuenta en un primer como hallazgo
que hicimos en esta investigación que
dice literalmente el miedo me detiene
para lograr mis sueños entonces yo tengo
un sueño pero no lo puedo lograr porque
tengo miedo porque me muero de miedo
literalmente entonces aquí lo que pasa
es que hay un círculo que podríamos
llamar como un círculo vicioso de la
infelicidad tengo miedo en este momento
entonces me paralizó no cumplo mis
sueños como no cumplo mis sueños dijo
frustrado y como vivo frustrado o
infeliz pues todavía tengo más miedo
entonces tengo más miedo me paralizó no
cumplo mis sueños no cumplo mis sueños
vivió frustrado y así todos tenemos este
círculo que yo le llamaría casi casi
neurótico dentro de cada uno de nosotros
porque todos tenemos un neuras dentro de
todos absolutamente todos y este círculo
de la infelicidad todos lo estamos
viviendo constantemente
entonces realmente todo lo que queremos
en esta vida es cambiar nuestra vida
mejorar nuestra vida queremos tener una
empresa queremos tener más dinero
queremos ser más queremos lograr más
queremos probablemente conseguir
nuestros sueños conseguir algo que
admiramos muchísimo nuestras metas pero
generalmente para cambiar nuestra vida
no se necesitan grandes cambios se
necesita probablemente un cambio de
perspectiva a la mejor pequeño entonces
el primer cambio de perspectiva que yo
tenía en mi vida es cuando tú tienes un
gran sueño cualquier sueño que tú puedas
tener es en combo en paquete muégano en
palanquetas y pegado va a venir un gran
miedo obvio porque porque es un gran
sueño estás soñando demasiado grande
es obvio somos seres humanos todos
tenemos miedo viene un gran miedo y eso
fue como la primera como decirlo como
que el primer sentimiento que yo viví en
estas competencias y en todo lo que pasa
en mi vida
obviamente me muero de miedo obviamente
porque porque es un gran sueño es algo
que quiero lograr es algo que quiero
conseguir entonces le preguntamos a la
gente
usted a que le tiene miedo
entonces piensa primero tú y esa es una
invitación para ustedes a qué le tienes
miedo
yo la verdad es que cuando hice esta
pregunta a las personas me quedé
paralizado con la respuesta y al mismo
tiempo muy identificado miedo a fracasar
miedo a falla
miedo al ridículo miedo al regaño miedo
a perder mi trabajo miedo perder algo o
alguien miedo a intentarlo y que se
burlen de mi miedo a que me muestre
débil pero sobre todo juntamos todos
estos miedos y nos dimos cuenta que
todos los miedos todos son yo lo
desconocido porque porque nunca hemos
estado ahí porque nunca hemos vivido eso
porque nunca hemos pisado ese territorio
entonces todos los miedos todos todos
todos los miedos que tenemos y que nos
están frenando nuestra vida son miedo a
lo desconocido entonces el miedo con
este miedo a lo desconocido nos hace
actuar en tres tipos de formas yo le
llamaría como de chile molt y pozole de
chile te escapas no es decir tengo un
gran sueño llega un gran miedo mejor
corro
ese es el chile el mole sería te
paraliza es decir tengo un gran sueño me
quedo freak lladó no y vimos el círculo
este vicioso de la infelicidad
entonces no hago nada no avanzo me quedo
completamente paralizado y el tercero
que es el pozoles que yo les diría vamos
por el pozole mejor es lo enfrentas es
decir tengo un miedo
voy por él voy por él y voy a
enfrentarlo completamente como
enfrentarlo cuando nosotros tenemos
estos grandes sueños ya dijimos queda
muy claro que tenemos vamos a tener
grandes miedos completamente normal
somos seres humanos va a pasar todos
tenemos miedos pero cuando tenemos estos
grandes miedos en realidad lo que está
sucediendo en nuestra vida es que
tenemos grandes retos entonces cuando tú
tienes un miedo un gran miedo en
realidad no es un gran miedo es un gran
reto en tu vida piensa que te da miedo
tomarlo como un reto nuestros miedos en
realidad tendríamos que empezar a
cambiar la perspectiva y hablar acerca
de retos son grandes retos entonces
fuimos con estas mismas personas y les
preguntamos a usted señora señor
jovencito jovencita le gustan los miedos
y el 72% de las personas nos dijo que no
les gustan los miedos pero una respuesta
como que no nos gustan los miedos
y sorpresivamente y yo voy a revisar la
investigación y si otra vez la
tabulación para garantizar que estos
porcentajes fueran correctos porque vean
bien lo que pasa cuando les preguntamos
a usted le gustan los retos y el 72% nos
dijo que si les gustan los retos y no
respondía con orgullo sí claro o no pues
a mí me gustan los retos pero lo que no
hemos terminado de entender es que mis
miedos en realidad son mis retos tus
miedos son tus retos las personas nos
contestaban si me gustan los retos pero
no me gustan los miedos pues qué crees
compass es lo mismo son sinónimos es
completamente lo mismo entonces para
esto diseñe yo una herramienta para
poder cambiar de miedos a retos una
herramienta que yo le llamo rompe miedos
entonces ahorita se las voy a explicar
vas a salir en mi vídeo te vas a hacer
famosísimo muchísimas gracias por
participar
y mis plumones muchísimas gracias
entonces para usar esta herramienta que
le voy a explicar ahorita que se llama
rompe miedos necesitamos pasar primero
por tres premisas la primera es
reconocer que tengo miedo reconocer que
tengo ese miedo el segundo es querer
romperlo es decir estoy motivado por
romperlo quiero hacer algo por romperlo
porque me está deteniendo en mi vida y
el tercero es romperlo lo que les dije
hace rato atreverte a romperlo atreverte
a romperlo como romper entonces para eso
yo diseñé este mi otra vida fui profesor
entonces pedí a este pizarrón
para enseñarles un poco mas
didácticamente jugando tengo un miedo y
esto es de la vida real no es inventado
y realmente lo que yo hago y lo he
utilizado con otras personas cuando
tengo un juego hago este diagrama que lo
pueda hacer una serviría una servilleta
en un papel en mi mente a la vez es en
el celular y cómo funciona imaginen que
esto es un triángulo bueno imaginen es
un triángulo
entonces aquí estás tú en medio
muy feliz
hay que griñán un poquito menos así muy
feliz no quedó así con las cejas está
muy feliz entonces tiene tres pilares
estos tres pilares se componen los voy a
poner aquí estos tres pilares se
componen el primer elemento yo le llamo
estudio y estudio no necesariamente me
refiero a la universidad a la primaria
la secundaria me refiero a cualquier
tema que te da miedo te vas a poner
empezar a estudiar acerca de ese tema
imaginemos que también hablar en público
vas a empezar a estudiar acerca de cómo
hablar en público el segundo pilar yo le
llamo la mente porque porque hay que
preparar nuestra mente para poder hablar
en público en este ejemplo entonces como
es preparar la mente visualización
afirmación meditación gratitud hay
muchísimas herramientas para preparar la
mente y la inteligencia emocional y la
tercera parte el tercer pilar yo le
llamo los maestros que tampoco me
refiero a los maestros de la universidad
son aquellos maestros esas personas que
ya están donde nosotros queremos estar
esas personas que ya lograron lo que
nosotros queremos lograr esas personas
que ya son lo que nosotros queremos ser
o esas personas que ya hacen
lo que nosotros queremos hacer entonces
una vez que tú te empieces y entonces
tomamos este ejemplo de hablar en
público pues tendría que juntarse con
maestros que ya hablan en público para
preguntarles para pedirles para
aconsejarles ellos nos inspiran y nos
motivan constantemente a cumplir
nuestros sueños en un eje en un eje así
yo lo pondría como punteado aquí
alrededor
yo veo la parte de la práctica
y cómo es esto si yo tengo miedo hablar
en público me voy a poner a estudiar
acerca de cómo hablar en público voy a
preparar mi mente todos los días de cómo
hablar en público voy a juntarme a
preguntar ya pedirle a mis maestros que
me enseñen cómo hablar en público y voy
a practicar constantemente como hablar
en público todo el tiempo y de repente
por casualidad el miedo se empieza a ser
chiquito chiquito chiquito chiquito y
pop para no hablar en público por
ejemplo cualquier miedo cualquier miedo
se puede romper cualquier miedo entonces
cuando tú haces este tipo de
herramientas empieza a tener una visión
una perspectiva un sentido del logro de
que el miedo siempre va a estar siempre
va a estar en nuestra vida pero se va a
ser chiquito y puedes avanzar para
construir tus sueños y entonces la
escala de cómo funciona esto es cuando
tú tienes un gran sueño por consecuencia
y por evidente porque ya lo vimos bien
va a venir un gran miedo son grandes
miedos esos grandes miedos los vamos a
convertir en grandes retos y esos
grandes retos en realidad los vamos a
llevar hacia los grandes logros
solamente así entonces cuando vemos este
tipo de imágenes la gente me dice oye
qué pasa de josé luís yo creo que tú
naciste con estrella tus papás aseguró
son empresarios
a lo mejor y desconocido ahí del
presidente como lo hiciste naciste con
estrella con un don natural y yo digo no
compás nací con este diagrama en mi
cabeza yo les estoy compartiendo que es
me cuesta estudiar cañón he preparado mi
mente todos los días constantemente
me he rodeado de muchísimos maestros que
a los que les agradezco todos mis logros
y cada uno de mis de mis pasos y he
practicado todo el tiempo todos los días
en mi vida hacia donde quiero llegar
entonces creo que no tengo que hacer un
estudio de mercado para entender que a
la mayoría de nosotros nos dan miedo los
cocodrilos a mi me ame los conjuros
entonces imaginemos que uno de mis
sueños en la vida para avanzar que
mantiene atorado y yo lo quiero romper
meter la cabeza adentro de un cocodrilo
vivo
no podría ser una lo podría ser sí lo
podría ser como me tengo que poner
estudiar acerca de los cocodrilos los
colmillos el ojo el hocico etcétera todo
todo todo lo que es el cocodrilo tengo
que preparar mi mente yo creo que sí
para meter la cabeza en truco y lo vivo
pues yo creo que sí tengo que preparar
mucho mi mente visualizarme afirmaciones
y gratitud ya se los dije juntarme con
personas que ya habían metido la cabeza
entre loco y lo vivo y practicar
constantemente como a lo mejor y lo que
con un cocodrilo de peluche primero
luego con un cocodrilo de plástico con
un poco de papel
luego hay mancity titolo un caimán más
grande lo un caimán más más un poquito
más maduro y después llegar a hacer
cosas como esta
este no soy yo en la foto obviamente
obviamente no soy yo y yo me parezco a
pero pero pero no no soy yo no soy yo
todavía porque no es mi sueño entonces
no conozco no no tengo el gusto de
conocer esta persona valiente pero
seguramente se puso estudiar de los
cocodrilos sabe hasta qué distancia
abrir la cabeza sabe qué onda con la
mente preparar constantemente su
inteligencia
sabe tema de los maestros seguramente
otros entrenadores los dueños del circo
no sé pues somos que le enseñaron a
hacer eso y práctica constantemente
entonces yo aquí voy a hacer un
paréntesis y voy a contradecir a muchas
personas que dicen están conferencias
que dicen si tienes miedo aviéntate a
ver compa si yo meto la cabeza entre
cocodrilos porque tengo miedo y me
aviento seguro me va a arrancar la
cabeza va a girar porque dicen que giran
no estoy hablando pero dicen que giran y
esto no será un vídeo de ted sería un
vídeo de mil formas de morir o algo así
no entonces si quieres romper tu miedo
no es aventar te como el borras es
preparar tu mente preparar obviamente
tus estudios preparar tus maestros y
practicar constantemente cualquier nos
podemos hacer esto en cualquiera de
nosotros y luego vemos imágenes como
esta y decimos oye cómo puede ser
posible que valiente como puede quedar
robar o como se atreve seguro su papá
striker o
seguro nació con estrella seguro tiene
un tono natural y yo digo no compa otra
vez seguro seguro se puso estudiar
fuertísimo de verdad acerca de la
distancia y la altura del viento de todo
el tema para cruzar esto preparó su
mente constantemente tiene maestros yo
creo que es y gente que le enseña cómo
hacer ahí los malabares o como se llame
esta travesía y se puso a practicar lo
mejor primero arrancó con una cuerda y
está así y luego así luego así luego
entre la casa el vecino y su casa luego
ya se fue a este tipo de hazañas que
vemos y decimos cómo le hizo tú cosas y
tú así nomás entonces la verdad es que
no hay receta secreta no hay pastilla
para el miedo no hay crema contra el
miedo no hay te contra el miedo si
alguien la tiene por favor me la da para
no echar tanto rollo me la paso para
tomarme la y listo pero la realidad es
que todo todo todo en la vida todo en la
vida requiere muchísima preparación y
trabajo duro esa es la fórmula es la
pastilla es la receta ese es el secreto
entonces
sucede que como tú te atreves a romper
el miedo rompes tu miedo cumple sus
sueños estás cumpliendo tus sueños vives
feliz
vives feliz me atrevo me atrevo rompo el
miedo rompo el miedo cumplo mis sueños
cumplo mis sueños vivo feliz y de
repente se te hace así como un tema como
adictivo y dicen es que este chavo gana
todos los premios como le hace 2 así
estudiando muchísimo contándome con
personas que me ayudan que me apoyan que
me hacen crecer en el tema de la mente
practicando durísimo y siendo muy feliz
obviamente así así atreviéndome
rompiendo el miedo convirtiéndolo en
retos cumpliendo mis sueños viviendo muy
feliz entonces la secuencia como debería
ser tengo un gran sueño todos tenemos un
gran sueño con este gran sueño van a
venir miedos sí porque somos humanos
pero sin miedo no va a haber un reto
porque porque si algo no me da miedo
entonces no es un reto sin retos no hay
logros porque si algo no me costó
trabajo pues entonces no fue un logro
pero que creen sin logros no hay
autorrealización y sin autorrealización
no hay felicidad
así de simple y entonces aquí la fórmula
si se dan cuenta en esta fórmula la
felicidad en este esquema de la
felicidad
los miedos forman parte de nuestra vida
los miedos forman parte de la felicidad
los mismos no son debilidad los míos no
son malos números son negativos ándate
con cuidado ándate sin miedo
eso no es no es debilidad son parte de
nuestra vida son parte de nuestra
fórmula entonces la pregunta es
qué miedo te está deteniendo a ti
el miedo que sea el que sea escuchando
bien el miedo que sea lo puede romper y
avanzar en tu vida el que sea y entonces
yo soy un claro ejemplo viviente de
carne y hueso soy una persona normal
tengo ni cu y q por debajo del promedio
soy una persona así normal
con sueños aspiraciones anormales con
acciones probablemente anormales pero
que demostrado que podemos lograr lo que
nos propongamos en nuestra vida y tú
puedes lograr lo que te propongas en la
vida si quieres meter la cabeza entre un
cocodrilo lo puedes lograr
si quieres poner tu empresa lo puedes
lograr
si quieres hablar en inglés francés
chino mandarín lo que sea lo puedes
lograr cualquier cosa la puedes lograr y
entonces realmente vamos a lograr ser
felices o llegar a ese punto de
realización una vez que entendamos que
nuestros miedos son nuestros retos
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]